Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. On Saturday, May 27, 1978, a thunderstorm lashed the U.S. state of Missouri. In the northwest city of St. Joseph, hundreds of locals braced the cold wet weather to trudge through the wooded banks of the Missouri River, beyond the railroad on the city's western edge.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。今天的剧集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1978年5月27日，星期六，一场雷暴袭击了美国密苏里州。在西北部的圣约瑟夫市，数百名当地人冒着寒冷潮湿的天气，艰难地穿过密苏里河树木繁茂的河岸，越过城市西侧的铁轨。
They were searching for something. Their path led beyond the well-worn walking tracks and into the dense foliage, where muddy conditions made for a hazardous track. As the sun began to set, their task became even more difficult. Determined and desperate, the searchers continued on with flashlight in hand, but with time and to the elements against them, it was only a matter of minutes before the search would be called off. Just as things were starting to wrap up for the night, one group came across some trampled undergrowth that led to an area of long weeds.
他们正在寻找某样东西。他们的路径延伸到人迹罕至的步道之外，进入茂密的植被中，泥泞的环境使道路变得危险。随着太阳开始落山，他们的任务变得更加艰巨。搜寻者们坚定而绝望，手持手电筒继续前行，但随着时间和自然环境对他们不利，距离搜寻行动被取消只剩下几分钟了。就在夜间的搜寻工作即将结束时，一组人偶然发现了一些被踩踏的灌木丛，通向一片长满杂草的区域。
Hidden within was something red and blue. Pulling back the foliage, the group found what they had been looking for. Meanwhile, at the nearby Hoof and Horn Steakhouse, exhausted members of the search party had gathered inside seeking refuge from the harsh weather. All of a sudden, the room fell silent as the restaurant's owner called out with the news they'd all been longing to hear. A collective sense of relief washed over the crowd, who erupted into a round of cheers and applause. Eric Christian had been found, and he was alive and well.
隐藏在里面的是红蓝相间的东西。拨开植被，搜寻小组发现了他们一直在寻找的目标。与此同时，在附近的“蹄与角”牛排馆，筋疲力尽的搜寻队员们聚集在室内，躲避恶劣的天气。突然，房间里安静了下来，餐馆老板喊出了他们一直渴望听到的消息。一种集体的解脱感席卷了人群，他们爆发出一阵欢呼和掌声。埃里克·克里斯蒂安被找到了，他安然无恙。
The mall in downtown St Joseph was unusually quiet for a Friday afternoon, as many local residents and business owners were spending the upcoming Memorial Day long weekend vacationing elsewhere. Karen Carter was looking forward to the three-day break ahead. She had just one more errand to run before finishing up work for the day. It was nearing 3pm when Karen wondered through the near empty mall on the lookout for a store that was both still open and had what she needed. Karen had been tasked with purchasing an American flag to display in her boss's office in honor of Memorial Day and the fallen military personnel it observed. She soon came across a bookstore that was still trading with American flags for sale.
圣约瑟夫市中心的购物中心在周五下午异常安静，因为许多当地居民和店主都去别处度假，度过即将到来的阵亡将士纪念日长周末。凯伦·卡特很期待即将到来的三天假期。在结束一天的工作之前，她还有最后一项差事要办。快到下午3点时，凯伦在几乎空无一人的商场里徘徊，寻找一家既开门又有她所需物品的商店。凯伦的任务是购买一面美国国旗，挂在她老板的办公室里，以纪念阵亡将士纪念日及其所缅怀的阵亡军人。她很快发现了一家仍在营业并出售美国国旗的书店。
As Karen approached the storefront, she felt a hand tighten around her own. Walking by her side was Eric Christian, her boss's four-year-old son. Eric was a familiar face in the Walnut Products Company office, which was owned by Eric's father, Edwin Christian. Karen had offered to take Eric with her to the mall so Edwin could focus solely on his managerial duties. Eric was enthusiastic about the trip, which included lunch at a fast-food restaurant as well as a drive in his father's Cadillac. But it was a small play area for children out the front of the bookstore that had Eric wide-eyed and excited. He beckoned Karen towards it and asked if he could play there while she
当凯伦走近店面时，她感到一只手紧紧抓住了她的手。走在她身边的是埃里克·克里斯蒂安，她老板四岁的儿子。埃里克是核桃产品公司办公室里的熟面孔，该公司由埃里克的父亲埃德温·克里斯蒂安拥有。凯伦主动提出带埃里克去商场，这样埃德温就可以专注于他的管理职责。埃里克对这次旅行非常兴奋，其中包括在快餐店吃午餐，以及乘坐他父亲的凯迪拉克汽车。但书店门前的一个小型儿童游乐区让埃里克瞪大了眼睛，兴奋不已。他示意凯伦过去，问她在他购物时他是否可以在那里玩耍。
shopped nearby. Karen, who would only be gone for a minute, agreed. When she came back out moments later, Eric was gone. View people in the vicinity of the bookstore had noticed the blonde haired blue-eyed Eric who was wearing a blue and red striped shirt with denim jeans. Of those who did, none had seen him leave. He wasn't found in the mall, its parking area, or anywhere else close by, making it highly unlikely he had simply wandered off. A witness soon came forward who'd seen a boy matching Eric's description half an hour after he disappeared from the mall, walking along the train tracks near the Missouri River on the western side of town. An older man was with him. Following this revelation, the search shifted from a little boy
凯伦同意了，她只会离开一分钟。当她片刻后回来时，埃里克不见了。商场附近的人们注意到了金发蓝眼的埃里克，他穿着一件蓝红条纹的衬衫和牛仔裤。在那些注意到他的人中，没有人看到他离开。他在商场、停车场或附近任何地方都没有被找到，这使得他只是走失的可能性极低。不久后，一名目击者站了出来，称在埃里克从商场失踪半小时后，看到一个符合埃里克特征的男孩，正沿着城西密苏里河附近的铁轨行走。一个年长的男人和他在一起。这一发现后，搜寻工作从寻找一个走失的小男孩转向了可能的绑架案。
lost to a possible abduction. Kidnapping didn't seem an outrageous possibility given the prominence and wealth of the Christian family. Even they assumed Eric had been taken, as he was an outgoing child who had no qualms talking to strangers. The Christian family waited anxiously overnight for word of a ransom demand, but only received calls from people offering their sympathies. After 24 hours passed with no sign of his son, Edwin Christian offered a $10,000 reward for Eric's safe return. He told reporters, I'm afraid some kook may have my son. I don't care about the money, I just want my son back. More than 500 local volunteers braved the wet and thunderous weather the following day,
考虑到克里斯蒂安家族的显赫和财富，绑架似乎并非不可能。甚至他们也认为埃里克是被带走了，因为他是一个外向的孩子，对与陌生人交谈毫无顾忌。克里斯蒂安一家焦急地等待了一整夜的消息，希望能有赎金要求，但只接到了人们表示同情的电话。在24小时过去且没有儿子踪迹后，埃德温·克里斯蒂安悬赏1万美元寻找埃里克的安全归来。他告诉记者：“我担心某个疯子可能带走了我的儿子。我不在乎钱，我只想找回我的儿子。”第二天，超过500名当地志愿者冒着潮湿和雷雨天气，
heading to the Missouri River to conduct a large-scale search of the area. By now, several more reports had come through from people who had seen a boy similar to Eric Christian walking along the adjacent train tracks with an unknown man. If these sightings were correct and Eric was out there, the harsh conditions posed a significant threat to his survival. The search lasted all day and into the night. Although they hadn't given up, hope of finding Eric alive was dwindling. As volunteers gathered in the Hoofenhorn Steakhouse for a short reprieve, news soon reached them that Eric had been found alive and well. Their celebrations were short-lived, as follow-up calls were made and reports clarified.
前往密苏里河对该地区进行大规模搜寻。到目前为止，又有几份报告称，有人看到一个类似于埃里克·克里斯蒂安的男孩与一名身份不明的男子沿着相邻的铁轨行走。如果这些目击情况属实，且埃里克确实在外面，那么恶劣的环境对他生存构成了重大威胁。搜寻工作持续了一整天，一直到深夜。虽然他们没有放弃，但找到活着的埃里克的希望正在减弱。当志愿者们聚集在“蹄与角”牛排馆稍作休息时，很快传来了埃里克被找到且安然无恙的消息。他们的庆祝活动很短暂，因为后续电话打来，报告得到了澄清。
Eric had indeed been found, however, he was deceased. His body lay hidden among the trees, weeds and bracken that framed the Missouri River, not far from the railroad. He had suffocated, but there was no evidence on or around him to definitely prove how. His unbuttoned genes hinted at what was later confirmed via autopsy. Eric had been sexually assaulted. In a move that horrified and disgusted locals, a photo of Eric's body lying in the brush was printed on the front page of the St. Joseph News Press. The newspaper's editor defended his decision against a wave of complaints, saying, We felt the picture might have beneficial results.
埃里克确实被找到了，但他已经去世了。他的尸体被隐藏在密苏里河边、铁轨附近树木、杂草和蕨类植物中。他窒息而死，但周围没有证据能明确证明原因。他解开的牛仔裤暗示了后来尸检证实的情况。埃里克遭到了性侵犯。在令当地人感到震惊和厌恶的举动中，一张埃里克尸体躺在灌木丛中的照片被刊登在《圣约瑟夫新闻出版社》的头版。报纸编辑反驳了针对他的投诉浪潮，称：“我们认为这张照片可能会产生有益的结果。”
If for no other reason than teaching adults not to leave children unattended in public places. Coincidentally, at the exact time that Eric was abducted, a reporter had been filming inside the mall as part of a documentary. 45 seconds of footage had panned across several storefronts, stopping in front of the bookstore just short of the children's play area. By pure luck, the play area had been captured in the reflection of one of the shop windows. Eric couldn't be detected in the footage, but a few adults were caught on camera. The footage was broadcast on the evening news, with police urging those featured within to come forward. Nobody did, but a local who lived half a mile from the crime scene reported that
如果仅仅是为了教育成年人不要让儿童在公共场所无人看管。巧合的是，在埃里克被绑架的同一时间，一名记者正在商场内拍摄一部纪录片。45秒的镜头扫过了几家店面，停在书店前，距离儿童游乐区仅一步之遥。纯属巧合，游乐区被捕捉到了其中一个商店橱窗的倒影中。埃里克在镜头中无法被辨认，但有几名成年人被拍到了。这段录像在晚间新闻中播出，警方敦促出现在镜头中的人站出来。没有人这样做，但一位住在距离犯罪现场半英里处的当地人报告说，
at around 1 a.m. on Saturday, they heard a short, sharp scream, followed by crying. Several witnesses had now come forward to report seeing a boy who matched Eric's description within the hour that he went missing. They all saw him walking along the train tracks near the Missouri River, with an older man tightly gripping his arm and leading him along. The boy didn't appear to be in any distress. The witnesses each underwent hypnosis in an effort to uncover more details, and a suspect sketch was created as a result of their descriptions. The man was described as 45 years old, around 6 feet tall and 200 pounds, with dark, graying hair. He walked with a strange gait, and held his right arm out at an odd angle.
在周六凌晨1点左右，他们听到了一声短促而尖锐的尖叫声，随后是哭声。现在有几名目击者站出来报告说，在埃里克失踪的那一小时内，看到了一个符合他特征的男孩。他们都看到他沿着密苏里河附近的铁轨行走，一个年长的男人紧紧抓住他的手臂领着他走。男孩看起来并没有任何痛苦。目击者们都接受了催眠，试图揭示更多细节，并根据他们的描述绘制了一张嫌疑人素描。该男子被描述为45岁，身高约6英尺，体重200磅，留着深色、灰白的头发。他走路姿势奇怪，右臂以一种奇怪的角度伸出。
Investigators questioned and cleared recent parolees from the Missouri State Penitentiary. They also paid a visit to a psychiatric hospital in St. Joseph, where a lack of security meant it was common for patients to occasionally wander from the grounds. But no escapees had been reported at the time of Eric Christian's murder. Yet, one staff member mentioned that a patient who had been admitted shortly after Eric's body was found had been exhibiting strange behavior. He repeatedly wrote Eric's name over and over on a piece of paper, but was ultimately eliminated from the investigation. 200 leads came through to detectives in the first few days of the investigation alone, but Eric's killer continued to allude them. Fearing he might strike again,
调查人员审问并排除了密苏里州立监狱最近的假释人员。他们还走访了圣约瑟夫的一家精神病院，由于缺乏安保，病人偶尔从院子里溜走是常有的事。但在埃里克·克里斯蒂安被谋杀时，没有报告有逃跑者。然而，一名工作人员提到，在埃里克的尸体被发现后不久入院的一名病人表现出奇怪的行为。他反复在一张纸上写着埃里克的名字，但最终被排除在调查之外。仅在调查的前几天，侦探们就收到了200条线索，但埃里克的杀手继续躲避着他们。担心他可能会再次作案，
the mayor of St. Joseph urged the community to keep a closer eye on their children. An editorial printed in the St. Joseph news press warned, Eric Christian was slain by someone whose derangements are a continuing threat to children as long as this person is loose among us. No family is safe, no child is safe. The FBI's Behavioral Science Unit concluded that the suspect was likely a white male who lived a quiet, solitary life, had never been married, and was either unemployed or worked a menial job near the side of Eric's abduction. 64-year-old Harry Fox fit the bill. An unwed introvert, Fox worked as a janitor in a 14-story law office known as the Corby Building,
圣约瑟夫市长敦促社区密切关注他们的孩子。《圣约瑟夫新闻出版社》刊登的一篇社论警告说：“埃里克·克里斯蒂安被一个精神错乱的人杀害，只要此人还在我们中间，对儿童来说就是一个持续的威胁。没有家庭是安全的，没有孩子是安全的。”联邦调查局的行为科学部门得出结论，嫌疑人很可能是一名白人男性，过着安静、孤独的生活，从未结过婚，要么失业，要么在埃里克被绑架地点附近从事卑微的工作。64岁的哈里·福克斯符合这些特征。福克斯是一个未婚的内向者，在科比大厦（一座14层的律师事务所大楼）担任清洁工，
located one block from the mall. He had a slight intellectual disability and had difficulty engaging in conversation, but was known to be friendly to children. He walked slowly, with his right arm held at an odd angle, much like the man seen walking along the train tracks with Eric Christian. The day Eric was abducted had been Fox's birthday. Harry Fox came to the attention of investigators after someone reported seeing a boy who matched Eric's description at the Corby Building on the day of his abduction. Investigators confronted Fox at work and told him off for questioning, telling his boss that he was a suspect in the Eric Christian murder. During his interrogation, Fox was clearly scared. An hour into questioning, he requested a drink
距离商场仅一个街区。他有轻微的智力障碍，难以进行对话，但以对孩子友好而闻名。他走路缓慢，右臂以奇怪的角度保持着，很像那个被看到与埃里克·克里斯蒂安一起沿着铁轨行走的男人。埃里克被绑架的那天正是福克斯的生日。哈里·福克斯在有人报告说在绑架当天在科比大厦看到一个符合埃里克特征的男孩后，引起了调查人员的注意。调查人员在工作中与福克斯对质，并告诉他的老板他是一名嫌疑人。在审讯过程中，福克斯显然很害怕。审讯进行了一小时后，他要求喝一杯
of water. After taking a few sips, Fox lent forward in his chair and put his head between his legs. Wheezing, shaking and then vomiting, Fox collapsed onto the floor, convulsing and gasping for breath. An ambulance was called, but it was too late. Harry Fox had died of a heart attack. His boss told reporters, I knew Harry Fox was here in the building from one to four p.m. the day the Christian boy was kidnapped, and I told the two officers about that when they talked with me. In hindsight, Fox's poor health and physical impairments made it impossible for him to have reached the Missouri River to kill Eric and dispose of his body. Fox was also significantly
水。喝了几口后，福克斯在椅子上向前倾，把头放在两腿之间。他喘着气，颤抖着，然后呕吐，倒在地板上，抽搐并喘不过气来。救护车被叫来了，但为时已晚。哈里·福克斯死于心脏病发作。他的老板告诉记者：“我知道哈里·福克斯在克里斯蒂安男孩被绑架那天下午1点到4点都在大楼里，当那两名警官与我交谈时，我告诉了他们这一点。”事后看来，福克斯糟糕的健康状况和身体残疾使他不可能到达密苏里河去杀害埃里克并处理尸体。福克斯也明显
heavier than the suspect seen walking on the railway tracks. Describing Fox as a lovable person, his manager said, it was inhumane for those officers to talk with him after I told them all about him. Harry Fox was posthumously dismissed as a suspect, with the owner of the Corby Building commenting, his death is the same as that little boy's. The weapons were arrogance and a lack of compassion. Telling the public that investigators were more or less at a dead end, St. Joseph Police Chief Robert Hayes spoke of the real last-ditch effort they were undertaking to re-examine all the tips so far received. One such tip, which had grown into a sizeable lead, was in relation to a suspect that investigators kept tight-lipped about. The man was well known around town as a
比在铁轨上看到的嫌疑人重得多。他的经理称福克斯是一个可爱的人，他说：“在告诉他们关于他的一切之后，那些警官还去审问他，这是不人道的。”哈里·福克斯在死后被排除了嫌疑，科比大厦的所有者评论说：“他的死和那个小男孩的死是一样的。武器是傲慢和缺乏同情心。”圣约瑟夫警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯告诉公众，调查人员几乎走进了死胡同，他谈到了他们正在进行的重新审查迄今为止收到的所有线索的最后努力。其中一条线索，已经发展成一条相当大的线索，与调查人员守口如瓶的一名嫌疑人有关。这个人在城里很有名，是一个
pest who regularly shoplifted and stole cars. He'd recently spent time in the state hospital where he was diagnosed with, quote, mental retardation and antisocial behavior. He also had a background of inappropriate sexual behavior towards children, specifically one incident where he bluntly asked a three-year-old relative to commit a sex act on him. Several witnesses had also placed him around the mall at the time Eric was there, including one who saw him walking towards the building moments before Eric's disappearance. When the police showed up at the home where Melvin Reynolds lived with his parents, he wasn't surprised. As detailed in the book Innocent Blood by Terry Ganey, Reynolds knew it was only a matter of time
经常入店行窃和偷车的害虫。他最近在州立医院待过一段时间，被诊断出患有“智力迟钝和反社会行为”。他还有对儿童进行不当性行为的背景，特别是一起事件，他直言不讳地要求一名三岁的亲戚对他进行性行为。几名目击者也将他置于埃里克在商场时的位置，包括一名看到他在埃里克失踪前片刻走向大楼的目击者。当警察出现在梅尔文·雷诺兹与父母居住的家中时，他并不感到惊讶。正如特里·盖尼在《无辜的血》一书中所述，雷诺兹知道这只是时间问题，
before they came knocking. He had considered leaving town until the heat died down, but knew that would draw suspicion. Instead, he opened the door and let the officers inside the house. Up to this point, the 25-year-old unemployed cook had been questioned about Eric Christian's murder on nine separate occasions within eight months. Reynolds had taken polygraph tests and agreed to be hypnotized, maintaining throughout that he wasn't at the mall when Eric Christian was present. He said that he had been at a hospital nearby visiting a friend and had parked his car at the Corby building, the same place where previous suspect Harry Fox worked. Reynolds claimed he then went to an unemployment office before returning home.
他们迟早会找上门来。他曾考虑在风头过去之前离开城镇，但知道这会引起怀疑。相反，他打开门，让警察进入屋内。到目前为止，这位25岁的失业厨师在八个月内因埃里克·克里斯蒂安的谋杀案被审问了九次。雷诺兹接受了测谎仪测试，并同意接受催眠，始终坚持他在埃里克·克里斯蒂安在场时不在商场。他说他当时在附近的一家医院探望朋友，并把车停在科比大厦，也就是之前的嫌疑人哈里·福克斯工作的地方。雷诺兹声称他随后去了失业办公室，然后回家了。
Yet, every time Reynolds was questioned, he incriminated himself further, with his version of events changing slightly in each retelling. Although he was initially cooperative, as time wore on, he became more irritated by the police's suspicion. Then, one day, investigators drove Melvin Reynolds to the local hospital to meet with a psychologist. While there, he was given a dose of sodium amatol through an IV line. Used as a sedative, the drug also had the reputation of being a truth serum that was used to Coke's unspoken or repressed memories from cagey suspects. When dosed, Reynolds became drowsy. The questioning then began.
然而，每次雷诺兹被审问时，他都会进一步自证其罪，他的事件版本在每次复述中都有轻微的变化。虽然他最初很配合，但随着时间的推移，他对警方的怀疑变得更加恼火。然后有一天，调查人员开车带梅尔文·雷诺兹去当地医院见心理学家。在那里，他通过静脉注射了一剂阿米妥钠。作为一种镇静剂，这种药物也被称为“吐真剂”，用于从狡猾的嫌疑人那里诱导出未说出口或被压抑的记忆。服药后，雷诺兹变得昏昏欲睡。审讯随即开始。
When asked if he had killed Eric Christian, Reynolds maintained he didn't have anything to do with it. But, as the sedative took further effect, he remarked, I saw the boy on the mall, before I killed. He then paused and backtracked, saying, before I went to the unemployment office. On Wednesday, February 14, 1979, nearly nine months after Eric Christian was killed, Melvin Reynolds sat with three police officers. Reynolds had said he was finally ready to confess, but he was finding it hard to talk. He was then offered an alternative. To save him from having to say what was troubling him,
当被问及是否杀害了埃里克·克里斯蒂安时，雷诺兹坚持说他与此事无关。但是，随着镇静剂进一步发挥作用，他评论道：“我在商场看到了那个男孩，在我杀人之前。”他随后停顿并改口说：“在我去失业办公室之前。”1979年2月14日，星期三，在埃里克·克里斯蒂安被杀近九个月后，梅尔文·雷诺兹与三名警官坐在一起。雷诺兹说他终于准备好坦白了，但他发现很难开口。然后他得到了一个替代方案。为了让他不必说出困扰他的事情，
he could instead write it down. Reynolds agreed and picked up a pen. He wrote of how he'd watched Eric Christian playing at the mall before approaching him, taking him by the hand, and walking him to the Missouri River. Once there, he sexually assaulted Eric. With this information now committed to paper, Reynolds permitted investigators to re-interview him on camera. He described the fear that Eric experienced and how the boy fainted during the attack, causing him to fall backwards and hit his head. Saying he was relieved to finally have it all off his chest, Reynolds added,
他可以把它写下来。雷诺兹同意了，拿起一支笔。他写下了他是如何看着埃里克·克里斯蒂安在商场玩耍，然后走近他，牵着他的手，带他走到密苏里河的。到了那里，他性侵了埃里克。有了这些写在纸上的信息，雷诺兹允许调查人员在摄像机前对他进行重新采访。他描述了埃里克经历的恐惧，以及男孩在袭击中昏厥，导致他向后倒下并撞到头。雷诺兹说他很高兴终于把这一切都说出来了，他补充道：
I just felt like it was going to catch up with me sooner or later. The officers then called in the county prosecutor Mike Insko, who listened as Melvin Reynolds confessed again, saying the words, I killed Eric Christian. The morning after Melvin Reynolds made these full admissions, he directed detectives to the area where he had killed Eric Christian and disposed of his body. He was then presented at the county courthouse, where he was charged with the four-year-old's second degree murder. He was held on a $50,000 bond at the county jail,
“我只是觉得迟早会被抓到。”警官们随后叫来了县检察官迈克·因斯科，他听着梅尔文·雷诺兹再次坦白，说出了“我杀了埃里克·克里斯蒂安”这句话。在梅尔文·雷诺兹做出这些全面供述后的第二天早上，他带领侦探们前往他杀害埃里克·克里斯蒂安并处理尸体的区域。随后他被带到县法院，被控犯有这名四岁男孩的二级谋杀罪。他被关押在县监狱，保释金为5万美元，
where he was segregated from other prisoners for his own safety, due to the nature of his crime. Prior to trial, Reynolds' attorney had him assessed at a psychiatric facility, believing that his client could plead guilty by reason of insanity if tests proved he was suffering from significant mental illness when he killed Eric. This would mean Reynolds would be incarcerated in a psychiatric facility rather than a prison. Within 35 minutes of interviewing Reynolds, the psychiatrist concluded that he'd been experiencing no serious mental illness at the time of Eric's murder. Melvin Reynolds was ordered to stand trial in October 1979. When he finally fronted court, it had been 500 days since Eric Christian was abducted.
由于他犯罪的性质，他被与其他囚犯隔离以确保自身安全。在审判前，雷诺兹的律师让他接受了精神病设施的评估，认为如果测试证明他在杀害埃里克时患有严重的精神疾病，他的当事人可以以精神错乱为由进行无罪辩护。这意味着雷诺兹将被关押在精神病设施而不是监狱。在采访雷诺兹35分钟后，精神科医生得出结论，他在埃里克被谋杀时没有患任何严重的精神疾病。梅尔文·雷诺兹被命令于1979年10月受审。当他最终出庭时，距离埃里克·克里斯蒂安被绑架已经过去了500天。
Reynolds opted to testify in his own defense, using his time in the witness box to recant his confession and profess his innocence. The overwhelming evidence against him ensured his pleas were ignored. After just three days of court proceedings and a further seven hours deliberation, the jury returned a verdict. For the second-degree murder of Eric Christian, Melvin Reynolds was found guilty. He was sentenced to life in prison. Prosecuting attorney Mike Insko said, We're lucky in this county to have such fine investigators. They checked, double-checked, and checked again to be absolutely sure they had the right man.
雷诺兹选择为自己辩护作证，利用他在证人席上的时间撤回了他的供词并声称自己无罪。针对他的压倒性证据确保了他的辩护被忽视。经过仅三天的法庭诉讼和随后的七小时审议，陪审团做出了裁决。因二级谋杀埃里克·克里斯蒂安，梅尔文·雷诺兹被判有罪。他被判处终身监禁。检察官迈克·因斯科说：“我们在这个县很幸运，有这么优秀的调查人员。他们检查、复查，再检查，以确保他们抓对了人。”
Michelle Steele was excited. She had never gone to the city alone before, so Monday, July 19, 1982 was a big deal. Mature for her 11 years of age, Michelle had been trusted by her parents to board a bus into downtown St. Joseph to attend a dentist appointment at 10.30am. But by 3.30pm, Michelle still hadn't returned home. Her mother phoned the dentist's office and learned Michelle had arrived on time for her morning appointment and spent almost an hour getting her braces adjusted. Then she left. That had been four hours ago. In scenes reminiscent of the disappearance of Eric Christian four years earlier, a crowd of volunteers joined police in conducting a large-scale search for Michelle.
米歇尔·斯蒂尔很兴奋。她以前从未独自去过城市，所以1982年7月19日，星期一，是一件大事。米歇尔11岁，心智成熟，父母信任她，让她独自乘坐公交车前往圣约瑟夫市中心，参加上午10点30分的牙医预约。但到了下午3点30分，米歇尔仍然没有回家。她母亲给牙医办公室打电话，得知米歇尔准时到达了上午的预约，并花了一个小时调整牙套。然后她离开了。那已经是四个小时前的事了。在让人想起四年前埃里克·克里斯蒂安失踪的情景中，一大群志愿者加入了警方的行列，对米歇尔进行了大规模搜寻。
The same team involved in investigating Eric's case was also assigned to Michelle's, and they were once again led by police chief Robert Hayes. He admonished Michelle's mother and left her in tears, saying, What kind of mother are you to let your little girl go down there alone? Don't you know about all the perverts down there? Michelle's father later addressed the criticism leveled at his family by stating, We let her go there alone, thinking people were safe. Obviously, that's not true. In circumstances that eerily mirrored Eric's abduction,
参与调查埃里克案件的同一团队也被指派负责米歇尔的案件，他们再次由警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯领导。他训斥了米歇尔的母亲，让她泪流满面，说道：“你是什么样的母亲，竟然让你的小女儿独自去那里？你不知道那里所有的变态吗？”米歇尔的父亲后来回应了针对他家人的批评，他说：“我们让她独自去那里，以为人们是安全的。显然，事实并非如此。”在与埃里克被绑架的情况惊人相似的情况下，
two separate witnesses had seen a young girl and a man walking along the tracks by the Missouri River the evening Michelle was abducted. Volunteer searches headed to the area, where in a muddy section of the riverbank, they found a small bright blue tennis shoe. It looked to have washed ashore from upstream. Michelle still's mother sobbed, confirming her daughter had been wearing the shoe the day she vanished. Suddenly, those searching the river and its surrounds heard someone yelling. Michelle's uncle Roy Montgomery emerged from the dense bush shouting loudly that he had found Michelle. He had noticed some trampled vegetation and shoe prints pressed into the mud leading
两名独立的目击者在米歇尔被绑架的当晚看到一个年轻女孩和一个男人沿着密苏里河的铁轨行走。志愿者搜寻队前往该地区，在河岸的一处泥泞地段，他们发现了一只小巧的亮蓝色网球鞋。它看起来像是从上游冲上岸的。米歇尔·斯蒂尔的母亲啜泣着，证实她的女儿在失踪那天穿的就是这只鞋。突然，那些在河边及其周边搜寻的人听到有人在喊叫。米歇尔的叔叔罗伊·蒙哥马利从茂密的灌木丛中走出来，大声喊着他找到了米歇尔。他注意到一些被踩踏的植被和压在泥里的鞋印，从
from the river to the nearby bluffs. Roy followed the trail until he came across two logs. Lying between them was Michelle's naked body having been partially concealed by large branches and foliage. She had been physically and sexually assaulted with imprints on her wrists indicating that she'd been restrained. There were also human bite marks across her body. As Michelle's body was taken from the site, one observer whispered between tears. It's happening all over again. Fear was now growing that a copycat was following in the footsteps of convicted killer Melvin Reynolds. Eric Christian and Michelle Steele's bodies were attacked in a similar manner and found within one mile of one another. Michelle's cause of death
河边一直延伸到附近的悬崖。罗伊沿着踪迹走，直到他遇到两根原木。躺在它们之间的是米歇尔赤裸的尸体，被大树枝和植被部分遮盖。她受到了身体和性侵犯，手腕上的印记表明她曾被束缚。她的身体上还有人类的咬痕。当米歇尔的尸体从现场被抬走时，一名观察者在泪水中低语：“这一切又发生了。”现在人们越来越担心一个模仿者正在追随被定罪的杀手梅尔文·雷诺兹的脚步。埃里克·克里斯蒂安和米歇尔·斯蒂尔的尸体以类似的方式受到攻击，并在彼此一英里内被发现。米歇尔的死因
was also suffocation as a result of her air supply being cut off while face down in the mud. Detectives were immediately suspicious of the circumstances in which Michelle was discovered. Specifically, the chances that her uncle Roy Montgomery happened to just stumble across her well-hidden remains. Michelle was described as sensible and responsible, leading detectives to believe that the only way in which she would be led to the remote area where she was found was if she was coaxed there by someone she knew and trusted. Within minutes of having announced the discovery of his niece's body, Roy Montgomery was swarmed by police and placed under arrest for her murder. Hours of questioning led to him being released
也是窒息，因为她的空气供应在脸朝下陷入泥中时被切断。侦探们立即对米歇尔被发现的情况产生了怀疑。特别是，她的叔叔罗伊·蒙哥马利恰好偶然发现她隐藏得很好的遗体的几率。米歇尔被描述为明智且负责任，这让侦探们相信，她被带到发现她的偏远地区的唯一方式是她被她认识和信任的人诱骗到那里。在宣布发现他侄女尸体的几分钟内，罗伊·蒙哥马利就被警察包围并因谋杀她而被捕。经过数小时的审问，他被释放，
without charge after a relative provided a solid alibi for his whereabouts. The focus then shifted onto another suspect. As night fell in the hours after Michelle Steele was reported missing, three fishermen on the Missouri River were quietly and diligently watching their rods, hoping to reel in a catfish. A little further up the riverbank, they noticed a man walking along with a radio in one hand and a canteen in the other. When he got within 10 yards of the fisherman, he asked if they were having any luck before quickly moving on. The fisherman were wary of the stranger, finding something unnerving about him. A few hours later, a volunteer in Michelle Steele's search party spotted the same man
没有受到指控，因为一位亲戚为他的行踪提供了可靠的不在场证明。焦点随后转移到另一名嫌疑人身上。在米歇尔·斯蒂尔被报告失踪后的夜晚，三名在密苏里河上的渔民正安静而勤奋地看着他们的鱼竿，希望能钓到一条鲶鱼。在河岸上方一点，他们注意到一个男人手里拿着收音机，另一只手拿着水壶走过来。当他走到距离渔民10码远的地方时，他问他们运气如何，然后迅速走开了。渔民们对这个陌生人保持警惕，觉得他身上有些令人不安的东西。几个小时后，米歇尔·斯蒂尔搜寻队的一名志愿者发现了同一个男人
sitting alone under an overpass and called out to ask if he'd seen a red-haired, freckled-faced girl. The man replied that he'd been fishing in the area all day and hadn't seen her. This comment struck the volunteer as odd, as the man didn't have any fishing gear with him. An hour later, two detectives looking for Michelle also crossed paths with the man. He told them he'd been fishing in the area all day, except that around 7pm, when he visited the Skaggs drugstore to purchase some alcohol. The detectives informed him that the drugstore closed at 6pm, and the man reasoned he must have lost track of time.
独自坐在立交桥下，大声询问他是否见过一个红头发、满脸雀斑的女孩。该男子回答说他整天都在该地区钓鱼，没有见过她。这个评论让志愿者觉得很奇怪，因为该男子身上没有任何钓鱼装备。一小时后，两名寻找米歇尔的侦探也与该男子擦肩而过。他告诉他们他整天都在该地区钓鱼，除了晚上7点左右，他去斯卡格斯药店买酒的时候。侦探们告诉他药店下午6点就关门了，该男子辩称他一定是忘了时间。
This was significant, as it had since been uncovered that after leaving the dentist, Michelle headed to Skaggs drugstore to buy some candy with pocket money her mother had given her. Suspicious of the man loitering by the river, detectives asked to see some identification. They ran a check on his name, Richard Harris, to see if he had any outstanding warrants, but he was given the all-clear and let go. The search for Michelle Steele continued, with little more thought given to Richard Harris. As it turned out, the location where detectives had confronted Harris was 10 yards from where Michelle's body was found hours later. Later that same morning, a security guard at the
这很重要，因为后来发现，米歇尔离开牙医后，去了斯卡格斯药店，用她母亲给她的零花钱买了一些糖果。侦探们怀疑这个在河边徘徊的男人，要求查看一些身份证件。他们核查了他的名字——理查德·哈里斯，看看他是否有任何未决的逮捕令，但他被证明清白并被放走了。对米歇尔·斯蒂尔的搜寻继续进行，对理查德·哈里斯的关注很少。事实证明，侦探们与哈里斯对质的地点距离几小时后发现米歇尔尸体的地方仅10码远。第二天早上，一名保安在
St. Joseph's State Mental Hospital received a call from the facility's switchboard operator. A distraught man had presented to the hospital, and was screaming and kicking the administration desk. The security guard rushed over, finding the man sobbing with his head in his hands and screaming. Make the voices quit. I can't stand them. They're scaring me. Rummaging through the man's bag, the security guard found some identification that determined him to be 53-year-old Iowa resident Richard Clarke. Clarke said he had been staying at the local Salvation Army Shelter, except for when he drank too much, at which point he stayed by the river.
圣约瑟夫州立精神病院接到了该设施总机接线员的电话。一名心烦意乱的男子出现在医院，正在尖叫并踢行政办公桌。保安冲了过去，发现该男子双手抱头啜泣并尖叫着：“让声音停下来。我受不了了。它们在吓我。”在翻找该男子的包时，保安发现了一些身份证件，确定他是53岁的爱荷华州居民理查德·克拉克。克拉克说他一直住在当地的救世军收容所，除非他喝得太多，那时他就会待在河边。
When detectives received word of Richard Clarke's antics at the hospital, they paid him a visit, and concluded that Richard Clarke and Richard Harris were one and the same. Now, they were even more suspicious, as moving around and using different surnames is typically a tactic used by those who don't want to be located or identified, and Richard Clarke had a history that he would want to distance himself from. In July 1982, Richard Clarke was at a grocery store when he set his sights on an 11-year-old boy. When the boy reached down to grab a bag of ice for his mother who was waiting outside, Clarke grasped his shoulder. Posing as a security guard, Clarke accused the boy of
当侦探们收到理查德·克拉克在医院闹事的消息时，他们拜访了他，并得出结论：理查德·克拉克和理查德·哈里斯是同一个人。现在，他们更加怀疑了，因为四处走动和使用不同的姓氏通常是那些不想被定位或识别的人使用的策略，而理查德·克拉克有一个他想要撇清关系的过去。1982年7月，理查德·克拉克在一家杂货店时，盯上了一个11岁的男孩。当男孩弯腰为在外面等候的母亲拿一袋冰块时，克拉克抓住了他的肩膀。克拉克冒充保安，指责男孩
being a man who had been in the hospital for a long time, but he didn't know what he was doing. He then escorted the boy through a door labelled Employees Only that led to a rear exit. Once outside, Clarke pulled the boy towards a nearby wooded area. Realising something was amiss, the boy yanked free of Clarke's grip and rushed back to his mother. The police were called, and Clarke was apprehended for attempted child abduction. The charges were ultimately dropped, but Clarke voluntarily checked himself into a psychiatric hospital and was released after two months. Less than three months later, Clarke confronted a man who had been in the hospital for two months.
是一个在医院待了很长时间的人，但他不知道自己在做什么。然后他护送男孩穿过一扇标有“仅限员工”的门，通往一个后出口。一旦到了外面，克拉克就把男孩拉向附近的一个树木繁茂的区域。意识到有些不对劲，男孩挣脱了克拉克的抓握，跑回了他的母亲身边。警察被叫来了，克拉克因企图绑架儿童而被捕。指控最终被撤销，但克拉克自愿住进了一家精神病院，并在两个月后出院。不到三个月后，克拉克与一名在医院待了两个月的男子对质。
Less than three months later, Clarke confronted a 19-year-old woman in downtown St Joseph and asked her to join him for coffee. Something about the look in his eyes terrified the woman, and she told him to go away and to leave her alone. The following day, Clarke approached a 10-year-old boy in a record store. This time, he claimed to be a police officer. He claimed to be a police officer and accused the boy of shoplifting before reaching to grab him by the arm. The boy ran off and alerted his grandmother, who was also in the store. By the time police arrived, Clarke had fled. It wasn't until he came to the attention of detectives investigating Michelle Steele's murder that he was linked to these two failed abduction
不到三个月后，克拉克在圣约瑟夫市中心与一名19岁的女子对质，并邀请她和他一起喝咖啡。他眼神中的某种东西吓坏了那个女人，她告诉他走开，离她远点。第二天，克拉克在一家唱片店接近了一个10岁的男孩。这一次，他声称自己是一名警察。他声称自己是一名警察，并指责男孩入店行窃，然后伸手去抓他的手臂。男孩跑开了，并通知了他的祖母，她也在店里。当警察赶到时，克拉克已经逃跑了。直到他引起调查米歇尔·斯蒂尔谋杀案的侦探们的注意，他才与这两起失败的绑架案联系起来。
attempts. Clarke had a relatively clean criminal record, aside from a charge for petty larceny for which he'd been fined $100, and his fingerprints didn't match any unsolved crime scenes in the FBI database. However, a wealth of forensic evidence linked him to the murder of Michelle Steele. Lengths of nylon cord found in Clarke's bag were the same width as the ligature marks on Michelle's wrist, and the muddy soles of his shoes matched the pattern of shoe prints leading to her body. The bites on Michelle's body also aligned with the dental impression of Clarke's teeth. When questioned about the crime, Clarke remained silent and refused to cooperate with police. By the following month of August, he was being held at the county jail on $250,000 bail,
克拉克的犯罪记录相对干净，除了因轻微盗窃罪被罚款100美元外，他的指纹与联邦调查局数据库中任何未解决的犯罪现场都不匹配。然而，大量的法医证据将他与米歇尔·斯蒂尔的谋杀案联系起来。在克拉克包里发现的尼龙绳长度与米歇尔手腕上的勒痕宽度相同，他鞋底的泥泞与通往她尸体的鞋印图案相符。米歇尔身上的咬痕也与克拉克牙齿的牙印吻合。当被问及这起犯罪时，克拉克保持沉默，拒绝与警方合作。到次年8月，他被关押在县监狱，保释金为25万美元，
having been charged with first-degree murder. While awaiting trial in early December 1982, Richard Clarke lay restrained to a chair in a psychiatrist's office with an IV line inserted into his veins. Sodium amadol was slowly moving through the tube and into Clarke's body, easing him into a state of near-unconsciousness. The doctor overseeing the procedure had carried it out years prior on convicted killer Melvin Reynolds. It had worked then to expedite a confession, and detectives were convinced that would do so again. When asked why he was at the Missouri River, a sedated Clarke replied that he was drinking and hearing voices. The voices ordered him not to talk to anyone and told him
并被控一级谋杀罪。在1982年12月初等待审判期间，理查德·克拉克躺在精神科医生办公室的椅子上，静脉里插着静脉注射管。阿米妥钠正缓慢地通过管子进入克拉克的身体，使他进入一种近乎无意识的状态。监督该程序的医生几年前曾在被定罪的杀手梅尔文·雷诺兹身上进行过同样的操作。当时它成功地促成了供词，侦探们确信这次也会奏效。当被问及为什么他在密苏里河时，处于镇静状态的克拉克回答说他在喝酒并听到声音。声音命令他不要和任何人说话，并告诉他
the same thing over and over. Clarke then grimaced and fell asleep. He was hastily shaken awake, which prompted him to blurt out. The voices told me to sacrifice a maiden. When asked if he followed the command, Clarke replied, Sometimes I think I did. Although the truth serum prompted Melvin Reynolds' confession to Eric Christian's murder, it didn't appear to have the same impact on Richard Clarke. He remained silent after his session, often spending his days lying unresponsive on the floor of his cell. Yet, a psychiatric report concluded. Clarke is mute by deliberate choice,
同样的事情一遍又一遍。克拉克随后做了个鬼脸，睡着了。他被匆忙摇醒，这促使他脱口而出：“声音告诉我牺牲一个处女。”当被问及他是否服从了命令时，克拉克回答说：“有时我想我做了。”虽然吐真剂促成了梅尔文·雷诺兹对埃里克·克里斯蒂安谋杀案的供述，但它似乎对理查德·克拉克没有同样的影响。他在审讯后保持沉默，经常整天躺在牢房的地板上毫无反应。然而，一份精神病学报告得出结论：“克拉克是故意选择沉默的，
as his mutism is observed to have a sudden onset after legal difficulties. His exaggerated mouth movements with squinting of the eyes and headbanging occur only when he believes he is being observed. It is my opinion that he does not have a mental disease or defect. A doctor at the St. Joseph's State Hospital called Clarke a professional faker, who knew how to fool people into thinking he was suffering from a significant mental illness. Then, almost six months after the truth serum was administered, Clarke scrawled a note on a piece of paper and slid it to a sheriff's deputy doing the morning rounds through the cell house. He had written,
因为他的缄默症被观察到在法律困难后突然出现。他夸张的嘴部动作、眯眼和撞头行为只有在他认为自己被观察时才会发生。我的意见是他没有精神疾病或缺陷。”圣约瑟夫州立医院的一名医生称克拉克是一个“职业骗子”，他知道如何愚弄人们，让他们认为他患有严重的精神疾病。然后，在吐真剂使用近六个月后，克拉克在一张纸上潦草地写了一张纸条，并把它滑给了一名正在牢房进行晨间巡视的警长副手。他写道：
please call the FBI and tell them I would like to see them today. Very important case. Special Agent Joseph Holtzlag had worked the Eric Christian case, and now he sat face-to-face with Richard Clarke, another accused child killer. Even though Clarke had summoned the FBI, he still wouldn't speak. Instead, he pulled out a small piece of folded paper from the inside of his sock and handed it to Agent Holtzlag. It was a segment of a map showing a city called Rock Island in the state of Illinois. The Mississippi River snaked its way through the map. Underneath were a set of directions which rad in part. On the arsenal side of the bridge, there's a guardrail on the right side. About the middle of the rail, look toward the bank.
“请给联邦调查局打电话，告诉他们我今天想见他们。非常重要的案件。”特别探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格曾参与埃里克·克里斯蒂安案，现在他与另一名被控杀害儿童的凶手理查德·克拉克面对面坐着。尽管克拉克召集了联邦调查局，但他仍然不说话。相反，他从袜子里掏出一张折叠的小纸条，递给了霍尔茨拉格探员。那是一张地图的一部分，显示了伊利诺伊州一个叫岩岛的城市。密西西比河蜿蜒穿过地图。下面是一组说明，部分内容如下：“在桥的兵工厂一侧，右侧有一个护栏。在护栏中间，看向河岸。
Walk about 10 feet to the bank. There's a steel rod sticking out. Go under the rod and look to your left about two feet. Dig under the rocks. You will find a body. Motioning with his hands that he had more to say, Clarke was handed a pen and paper. He wrote, come back after you find it. The next day, an FBI field agent armed with Clarke's map made his way along the bridge in Rock Island, then down to the bank of the Mississippi River. There he came across a steel rod, just as Clarke had forewarned. There was also something else sticking out of the mud nearby. It was a human thigh bone. An entire skeleton was soon excavated from the riverbed,
走到河岸边约10英尺处。有一根钢筋伸出来。钻到钢筋下面，向左看约两英尺。在岩石下挖。你会发现一具尸体。”克拉克用手势表示他还有话要说，有人递给他笔和纸。他写道：“找到它后再回来。”第二天，一名携带克拉克地图的联邦调查局外勤探员沿着岩岛的桥走，然后下到密西西比河岸边。在那里，他发现了一根钢筋，正如克拉克预先警告的那样。附近泥里还有别的东西伸出来。那是一根人类大腿骨。整个骨架很快从河床中被挖掘出来。
dressed in fragments of a light-colored shirt, a red jacket, and denim jeans. A pair of socks and shoes were also uncovered close by. Following this discovery, FBI Special Agent Joseph Holtzlag met with Richard Clarke again. He still refused to speak, but did write down. James Churchill, 34 years old, from Galesburg, Illinois. James Churchill had spent the majority of his life in a mental health facility due to his intellectual and physical disabilities. It was during his hospitalization that he met Richard Clarke. At age 31, James was deemed safe to re-enter society and was released from hospital. In June 1981, James stopped collecting his social security checks.
身上穿着浅色衬衫、红色夹克和牛仔裤的碎片。附近还发现了袜子和鞋子。这一发现之后，联邦调查局特别探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格再次会见了理查德·克拉克。他仍然拒绝开口，但写下了：詹姆斯·丘吉尔，34岁，来自伊利诺伊州盖尔斯堡。詹姆斯·丘吉尔因智力和身体残疾，大半生都在精神卫生机构度过。正是在住院期间，他结识了理查德·克拉克。31岁时，詹姆斯被认为可以安全回归社会并出院。1981年6月，詹姆斯停止领取社会保障金。
When a concerned nurse carried out a welfare check at his last known address, it was discovered that James had vanished without a trace. Two years later, his skeletal remains were found buried along the Mississippi River. Richard Clarke opened up about killing James, writing down that on the night of Saturday, June 20, 1981, he was with James on the bank of the river. Unbeknownst to James, Clarke had been fighting the urge to kill someone all day and had a butcher's knife concealed in his coat pocket. Clarke walked over to James and, quote, began stabbing him over and over in the chest until the knife became embedded in a bone near the heart. When Clarke visited the murder scene two weeks later, he was dismayed to discover
当一位负责的护士在他最后已知的住址进行福利检查时，发现詹姆斯已消失得无影无踪。两年后，他的遗骸在密西西比河沿岸被发现。理查德·克拉克敞开心扉承认杀害了詹姆斯，写道1981年6月20日星期六晚上，他和詹姆斯在河岸边。詹姆斯不知道的是，克拉克整天都在压抑杀人的冲动，外套口袋里藏着一把屠刀。克拉克走到詹姆斯身边，引用他的话，“开始反复刺向他的胸部，直到刀子嵌入心脏附近的骨头里。”当克拉克两周后再次造访案发现场时，他惊恐地发现
that James's body was gone. The stench of decomposition lingered in the air and Clarke followed it for 10 feet where he came across James's body. It was then he realized that James had initially survived the attack and had crawled across the riverbank after Clarke left, only to succumb to his injuries where he now lay. James's remains were in view of passes by, so Clarke worked to cover them with rocks and wood. That was all Clarke was willing to reveal to FBI agent Holtzlag about James Churchill's murder, writing that he'd give more answers in time. Exasperated, Holtzlag asked Clarke if there were any more bodies, and if so, how many. Clarke stared motionless at the wall for 10 minutes,
詹姆斯的尸体不见了。空气中弥漫着腐烂的恶臭，克拉克顺着气味走了10英尺，发现了詹姆斯的尸体。这时他才意识到，詹姆斯最初在袭击中幸存了下来，并在克拉克离开后爬过了河岸，最终因伤势过重倒在了那里。詹姆斯的遗骸在路人可见的范围内，所以克拉克设法用石头和木头掩盖了它们。这就是克拉克愿意向联邦调查局探员霍尔茨拉格透露关于詹姆斯·丘吉尔谋杀案的全部内容，他写道以后会给出更多答案。霍尔茨拉格气急败坏地问克拉克是否还有其他尸体，如果有，有多少具。克拉克盯着墙壁一动不动地看了10分钟，
hardly blinking. He then retrieved his pen and paper and continued writing. 16 total that I know of for sure. All adults except three. All males. Agent Holtzlag sat stunned before the self-professed serial killer. Although he had never met Richard Clarke prior to his work on the Michelle Steel case, from the moment they met, Holtzlag was overcome with a nagging feeling of familiarity, but he could never pinpoint why. Then one morning, as Holtzlag watched Clarke write out more information about his crimes, it dawned on him. It was the way Clarke, a tall, heavy-set man aged in his 50s, walked into the interview room with a strange gait and his right arm held out
几乎没有眨眼。然后他拿起笔和纸继续写道：据我所知总共有16个。除了三个以外都是成年人。全是男性。探员霍尔茨拉格坐在自称连环杀手的凶手面前感到震惊。虽然他在处理米歇尔·斯蒂尔案件之前从未见过理查德·克拉克，但从他们见面的那一刻起，霍尔茨拉格就被一种挥之不去的熟悉感所笼罩，但他无法确定原因。一天早上，当霍尔茨拉格看着克拉克写下更多关于他罪行的信息时，他突然明白了。那是克拉克——一个50多岁、身材高大的壮汉——走进审讯室时那种奇怪的步态，以及他右臂保持的姿势。
at a crooked angle. All of a sudden, Holtzlag was hit with the realization as to why Clarke seemed like someone he had known for some time. Agent Holtzlag looked at Clarke as he scribbled down notes and said, Eric Christian. Richard Clarke glanced up from his writing and smiled. Richard Clarke, Richard Harris, Richard Grady, Richard Price, Albert Eyre, Albert Price, Ronald Springer and Charles Tidwell were just some of the aliases used by Charles Ray Hatcher throughout his life. He had 14 in total, with four different birth dates and six social security numbers. In truth, he was born in 1929 in Mound City, Missouri. His father, an alcoholic ex-convict, was a violent man who beat Hatcher and his three brothers often.
呈一个扭曲的角度。突然间，霍尔茨拉格意识到为什么克拉克看起来像他认识已久的人。探员霍尔茨拉格看着正在记笔记的克拉克说：埃里克·克里斯蒂安。理查德·克拉克从写作中抬头笑了笑。理查德·克拉克、理查德·哈里斯、理查德·格雷迪、理查德·普莱斯、阿尔伯特·艾尔、阿尔伯特·普莱斯、罗纳德·斯普林格和查尔斯·蒂德韦尔，这些只是查尔斯·雷·哈彻一生中使用过的部分化名。他总共有14个化名，四个不同的出生日期和六个社会保障号码。事实上，他于1929年出生在密苏里州的芒德城。他的父亲是一名酗酒的前罪犯，是一个暴力的人，经常殴打哈彻和他的三个兄弟。
One day, the Hatcher boys fashioned a kite and took turns flying it, with Charles the last in line to play. As his brother prepared to hand the kite over, it made contact with an overhead power line. They had fashioned the kite using copper wire instead of string, causing Hatcher's brother to be electrocuted and die instantly. Witnessing this marked a turning point in Hatcher's life. The once quiet and intelligent boy became unruly. By age 16, he was living in St Joseph, working menial jobs. His first criminal conviction came at age 18 for stealing a car. Upon Hatcher's release from prison, he continued committing crimes, adding breaking and entering and forgery to his growing list. Hatcher's behavior took a sinister turn when he turned 29.
有一天，哈彻家的男孩们做了一个风筝轮流放，查尔斯排在最后。当他的兄弟准备把风筝递过来时，风筝碰到了头顶的电线。他们用铜线代替绳子制作风筝，导致哈彻的兄弟当场触电身亡。目睹这一幕成了哈彻人生的转折点。曾经安静聪明的男孩变得桀骜不驯。16岁时，他住在圣约瑟夫，做着卑微的工作。他第一次刑事定罪是在18岁时因偷车。哈彻出狱后继续犯罪，在他不断增加的罪名清单中又加上了入室盗窃和伪造罪。哈彻的行为在他29岁时发生了险恶的转变。
One day, he armed himself with a butcher's knife and brandished it at a 16-year-old newspaper delivery boy he intended to abduct. The teen escaped and Hatcher was sentenced to five years' prison, with time added following a failed breakout attempt. While incarcerated, Hatcher was shipped back and forth between psychiatric facilities and prison, as he was adept at falling guards, judges and medical professionals into believing he was suffering mental illness. He'd go long periods without talking, hit his head, and make strange facial expressions, earning him the nickname Crazy Charlie. Most knew not to interact with Charles Ray Hatcher, who was unpredictable and violent.
有一天，他带着一把屠刀，向一名他打算绑架的16岁送报男孩挥舞。少年逃脱了，哈彻被判处五年监禁，因越狱未遂又被加刑。在服刑期间，哈彻在精神病院和监狱之间被来回转送，因为他擅长欺骗狱警、法官和医疗专业人员，让他们相信他患有精神疾病。他会长时间不说话、撞头、做奇怪的面部表情，这为他赢得了“疯狂查理”的绰号。大多数人都知道不要与查尔斯·雷·哈彻互动，因为他不可预测且暴力。
In January 1961, Jerry Tharrington was sent to Missouri State Penitentiary. He had been caught stealing farm equipment that he planned to sell to pay for his wife's medical bills after she suffered a miscarriage. Tharrington was sentenced to two years' imprisonment, but would be eligible for release after just seven months. Until that time, Tharrington proved himself a model prisoner, wanting more than anything to be reunited with his wife. Six months into his incarceration, Tharrington was found on the floor of the prison kitchen, stabbed to death with a large knife. He had also been raped prior to his murder. The 11 inmates who were regularly assigned to kitchen duty were questioned,
1961年1月，杰里·萨林顿被送往密苏里州立监狱。他因偷窃农具被捕，他本打算卖掉这些农具来支付妻子流产后的医疗费。萨林顿被判处两年监禁，但仅七个月后就有资格获释。在此期间，萨林顿表现得像个模范囚犯，他最渴望的就是与妻子团聚。入狱六个月后，萨林顿被发现死在监狱厨房的地板上，被一把大刀刺死。他在被谋杀前还遭到了强奸。11名被指派在厨房工作的囚犯受到了审讯，
and only one was unaccounted for at the time of the attack, Charles Ray Hatcher. Without any hard evidence to prove his involvement, Hatcher was only given a 10-month stint in solitary confinement. He was released into the public two years later, after serving four years out of his five-year sentence. Over the next six years, Hatcher returned to prison another four times to serve short stints for burglary and car theft. His growing criminal record went undetected by authorities as he was constantly moving from state to state and using different aliases. In August 1969, he escaped a Kansas State prison farm and made his way to the West Coast. Eight days later in San Francisco,
只有一个人在袭击发生时下落不明，那就是查尔斯·雷·哈彻。由于没有确凿证据证明他参与其中，哈彻仅被判处10个月的单独监禁。两年后，他在服完五年刑期中的四年后被释放到社会。在接下来的六年里，哈彻又四次入狱，因入室盗窃和偷车服了短刑。他不断增加的犯罪记录未被当局发现，因为他不断在各州之间流窜并使用不同的化名。1969年8月，他从堪萨斯州的一个监狱农场逃脱，前往西海岸。八天后在旧金山，
he lured a five-year-old boy away from his home before sexually assaulting him. A witness who stumbled across the attack in progress summoned police, and the boy was rescued while Hatcher was arrested. He gave his name as Albert Price, and an ID in his possession bore the name Hobart Prater, but his fingerprints exposed his true identity within the system. With his crime described by one detective as the worst case of child molestation he had ever seen, Hatcher was charged with kidnapping and attempt to commit sodomy. As he awaited trial, Hatcher pretended he was insane to avoid going to prison. He spoke of violent and disturbing delusions and hallucinations,
他将一名五岁男孩从家中诱走并对其进行了性侵犯。一名偶然目击袭击过程的证人报了警，男孩获救，哈彻被捕。他自称是阿尔伯特·普莱斯，身上携带的身份证件名字是霍巴特·普拉特，但他的指纹在系统中暴露了他的真实身份。由于他的罪行被一位侦探描述为他所见过的最严重的猥亵儿童案，哈彻被控绑架和企图鸡奸。在等待审判期间，哈彻假装精神失常以逃避入狱。他谈论着暴力和令人不安的妄想和幻觉，
and of having visions of naked and bloody children. It was all an act, and it worked. Over the next three years, he was sent for psychiatric assessment five separate times. On each occasion, he was found competent to stand trial and sent back to prison, where court-appointed psychiatrists declared him unfit again, and returned him for more evaluations. He managed to escape one hospital only to be caught again a week later under the alias Richard Grady. He immediately resorted to the same, quote, Crazy Charlie theatrics, to avoid imprisonment. But his true identity was uncovered and he was sent back to prison. Given the nature of his crimes, Hatcher was terrified of what other
以及看到裸体和血淋淋的孩子的幻象。这一切都是表演，而且奏效了。在接下来的三年里，他被五次送去进行精神评估。每次他都被认定有能力受审并被送回监狱，而法院指定的精神科医生再次宣布他不适合受审，并将他送回进行更多评估。他曾设法从一家医院逃脱，但一周后又以理查德·格雷迪的化名被抓获。他立即诉诸同样的“疯狂查理”戏码以逃避监禁。但他的真实身份被揭穿，他被送回了监狱。鉴于他罪行的性质，哈彻非常害怕其他
inmates would do to him. He penned a letter to his public defender, complaining that his current prison did not have the facilities he required as a, quote, mentally disordered sex offender. The letter worked against Hatcher, as it was so articulate, approved he was capable of rational thinking and could therefore face trial. He was found guilty of lewd and lascivious conduct and sent to a hospital that he tried to escape from three months later. He was subsequently moved to a prison. Subject to regular reviews, one psychiatrist concluded Hatcher was a manipulative, dangerous and institutionalised sociopath. Another said he had a very poor prognosis for rehabilitation. Nevertheless, in 1976, he received a glowing report from a corrections
囚犯会对他做什么。他写信给他的公设辩护人，抱怨他所在的监狱没有他作为“精神障碍性犯罪者”所需要的设施。这封信反而对哈彻不利，因为它写得非常清晰，证明他有理性思考的能力，因此可以接受审判。他被判犯有淫秽和猥亵行为，并被送往一家医院，三个月后他试图从那里逃跑。随后他被转移到监狱。经过定期审查，一位精神科医生得出结论，哈彻是一个操纵性强、危险且制度化的反社会者。另一位医生说他的康复前景非常渺茫。然而，1976年，他收到了一份来自惩教人员的溢美之词报告，
counsellor who said, Reports indicate he is doing outstanding work. His effort, conduct, cooperation and initiative have also been excellent. Subject is certainly more outgoing and his progress has been commented on by staff members as well as his peer group. He has shown signs of accepting responsibility for his behaviour. As a result, Charles Ray Hatcher was paroled in May 1977, less than eight years after attacking the five-year-old boy in San Francisco. Within a week, he violated his parole conditions and fled the city. A crime spree followed, during which Hatcher, posing as a police officer tasked with finding child runaways, abducted a twelve-year-old boy from a bus stop. He took him to a boarding
报告称：“报告显示他工作表现出色。他的努力、行为、合作和主动性也非常优秀。该对象确实更加外向，他的进步也得到了工作人员及其同伴的评价。他表现出了承担行为责任的迹象。”因此，查尔斯·雷·哈彻于1977年5月获得假释，距离他在旧金山袭击那名五岁男孩还不到八年。一周之内，他违反了假释条件并逃离了该市。随后发生了一系列犯罪，哈彻冒充负责寻找离家出走儿童的警察，从公交车站绑架了一名12岁男孩。他把他带到一家寄宿
house and sexually assaulted him at Knife Point. The boy escaped when Hatcher passed out drunk. Upon his capture, Hatcher spent some time between 1978 and 1982 in prison. When released, he assaulted and attempted to stab a seven-year-old boy, tried to assault and sodomize a 17-year-old boy and attempted to stab a man. Each crime was committed in a different city and sometimes in a different state, with Hatcher always providing a different name to authorities. Yet again, he presented as mentally unstable and was shifted between mental health facilities until he was released back into the public. Despite having the status of a parolee at large, no one thought to fingerprint Charles Ray Hatcher and determine his true identity
旅馆，并在刀尖威胁下对他进行了性侵犯。当哈彻醉酒昏迷时，男孩逃脱了。被捕后，哈彻在1978年至1982年间在监狱里度过了一段时间。获释后，他袭击并试图刺伤一名七岁男孩，试图袭击并鸡奸一名17岁男孩，并试图刺伤一名男子。每起罪行都在不同的城市甚至不同的州发生，哈彻总是向当局提供不同的名字。他再次表现出精神不稳定，并在精神卫生机构之间被转送，直到他再次被释放到社会。尽管处于假释在逃状态，但没有人想到要对查尔斯·雷·哈彻进行指纹识别，以确定他的真实身份
and extensive history of violent offending. A prosecuting attorney for Omaha's Douglas County later told the St. Louis Post a dispatch newspaper, I suppose if he stayed in the criminal system here, ultimately we would have tried to do some background on him and tried to confirm who he was. He was in and out of our clutches so quick. I think everybody thought he's crazy and he's not coming back to court, and that was the end of it. I don't know how you stop a guy like that. Before he wound up in prison in 1978 for abducting and assaulting the 12-year-old boy from the bus stop, Charles Hatcher committed one crime which he got away with. In the late afternoon of Friday,
和广泛的暴力犯罪史。奥马哈道格拉斯县的一名检察官后来告诉《圣路易斯邮政快报》：“我想如果他一直留在我们的刑事系统中，最终我们会尝试对他进行背景调查并确认他是谁。他进出我们掌控的速度太快了。我想每个人都认为他疯了，不会再回法庭了，事情就这样结束了。我不知道该怎么阻止那样的人。”在1978年因绑架和袭击公交车站的12岁男孩而入狱之前，查尔斯·哈彻犯下了一起他侥幸逃脱的罪行。1978年5月26日星期五的傍晚，
May 26, 1978, Hatcher entered a mall in downtown St. Joseph and came upon four-year-old Eric Christian. The little boy had only been left alone for just a moment. Still, it was enough time for Hatcher to strike. Sitting before FBI Special Agent Joseph Holtzlag almost five years to the day after he carried out the attack, Charles Ray Hatcher fully confessed to the abduction, assault, and murder of Eric Christian. He said he'd been overcome with the familiar urge to kill, so he took Eric by the hand, walked him out of the mall, along the train tracks, and into the secluded wilderness by the Missouri River. There, he sexually assaulted Eric and choked him to death, managing to do so without leaving a mark. Then he covered Eric's body with
哈彻进入圣约瑟夫市中心的一家商场，遇到了四岁的埃里克·克里斯蒂安。小男孩只是被单独留下一会儿。尽管如此，这已经足够让哈彻下手了。在实施袭击近五年后的那天，查尔斯·雷·哈彻坐在联邦调查局特别探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格面前，完全供认了绑架、袭击和谋杀埃里克·克里斯蒂安的罪行。他说他被熟悉的杀人冲动所淹没，于是牵着埃里克的手，带他走出商场，沿着铁轨，进入密苏里河旁偏僻的荒野。在那里，他性侵了埃里克并将他勒死，设法做到没有留下痕迹。然后他用
branches before leaving town. Agent Holtzlag didn't doubt Hatcher's confession. He always believed Melvin Reynolds was innocent and that someone else was responsible for Eric's murder. In his confession, Reynolds claimed to have been watching Eric at the playground for 30 minutes before approaching him. But this was impossible, given that Eric had only been left alone for a couple of minutes. When Reynolds took detectives to the area where Eric's body had been dumped, he pointed out the approximate location, but required prompting to point out the exact spot. The crime scenes whereabouts were well known, given that the St. Joseph news press had printed a photo of Eric's body when it was found on the front page of their paper.
树枝覆盖了埃里克的尸体，然后离开了小镇。探员霍尔茨拉格并不怀疑哈彻的供词。他一直认为梅尔文·雷诺兹是无辜的，另有其人应对埃里克的谋杀负责。在供词中，雷诺兹声称在接近埃里克之前，他在操场上观察了他30分钟。但这是不可能的，因为埃里克只被单独留下了几分钟。当雷诺兹带侦探去抛尸地点时，他指出了大致位置，但需要提示才能指出确切地点。案发地点众所周知，因为《圣约瑟夫新闻报》在埃里克的尸体被发现时，在头版刊登了他的照片。
Various media outlets had also reported details about the location, and with so many locals involved in the search, word quickly got around. Witness descriptions of Eric being seen with the heavy-set older man matched Hatcher, but didn't match Reynolds, who was only 25 years old at the time with a slim build. As for the claims that Reynolds had propositioned a three-year-old to perform a sex act on him, this was found to be categorically untrue. Reynolds had been walking with the toddler when a person drove by and yelled out a derogatory remark. In response, Reynolds yelled back, suck my cock. The three-year-old clarified this to be the correct version of events, and the reality was that Reynolds had no history of sexual deviancy at all.
各种媒体也报道了有关该地点的细节，随着这么多当地人参与搜寻，消息很快传开了。目击者描述埃里克与一名身材魁梧的老年男子在一起，这与哈彻相符，但不符合当时只有25岁、身材瘦削的雷诺兹。至于雷诺兹曾向一名三岁幼儿提出性行为要求的说法，这被证实是完全不真实的。雷诺兹当时正带着那个幼儿走路，有人开车经过并大喊了一声侮辱性的话。作为回应，雷诺兹回喊道：“吸我的鸡巴。”那个三岁幼儿澄清这是事件的正确版本，事实是雷诺兹根本没有任何性变态史。
Most importantly, Reynolds' neighbour had come forward to police prior to his trial with a major revelation. At around 3.25pm on the day Eric Christian was abducted, she had struck up a conversation with Reynolds on his front porch. This was around the same time that Eric was taken from the mall. The neighbour had no reason to protect Reynolds, whom she openly admitted to detesting. She was reluctant to come forward, telling the press, I wish I didn't remember this, but I do. I don't want to be involved, but if I didn't say what I did, I wouldn't be doing what's right. St. Joseph Police Chief Robert Hayes was so certain of Reynolds' guilt that this alibi went ignored.
最重要的是，雷诺兹的邻居在审判前向警方透露了一个重大发现。在埃里克·克里斯蒂安被绑架当天的下午3点25分左右，她曾在前廊与雷诺兹交谈。这大约是埃里克从商场被带走的时间。邻居没有理由保护雷诺兹，她公开承认讨厌他。她不愿站出来，告诉媒体：“我希望我不记得这件事，但我记得。我不想卷入其中，但如果我不说出我所知道的，我就没有做正确的事。”圣约瑟夫警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯对雷诺兹的罪行如此确信，以至于这个不在场证明被忽略了。
Melvin Reynolds claimed he had only confessed to Eric's murder after relentless interrogations from the detectives. With a slight intellectual disability and a willingness to please, Reynolds was highly vulnerable to manipulation. During a polygraph test in the early investigation, he denied killing Eric before pausing and saying, but I'll say so if you want me to. He made a similar remark during a second polygraph test, prompting the operator to raise his concerns with Police Chief Robert Hayes, along with his belief that Reynolds was innocent. In response, Chief Hayes took the operator off the case. Melvin Reynolds was certain the truth would come out at his trial, leading to an acquittal.
梅尔文·雷诺兹声称他只是在侦探们无休止的审讯后才承认谋杀了埃里克。由于轻微的智力障碍和讨好他人的意愿，雷诺兹极易受到操纵。在早期调查的一次测谎仪测试中，他在否认杀害埃里克后停顿了一下说：“但如果你想让我这么说，我会说的。”他在第二次测谎仪测试中也说了类似的话，促使操作员向警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯提出了他的担忧，以及他认为雷诺兹是无辜的看法。作为回应，海耶斯局长将该操作员从案件中撤职。梅尔文·雷诺兹确信真相会在审判中大白，从而获得无罪释放。
He was shocked to have been found guilty and sentenced to life in prison, where he continued to profess his innocence. Prison life was particularly difficult for Reynolds, as he was convicted for a crime against the child, he endured violence and rape at the hands of his fellow inmates. From prison, he told a reporter that he felt targeted by authorities because he was gay. Reynolds' attorney echoed this sentiment, adding that the rampant homophobia present in St. Joseph meant his client had about as much chance of fitting in and being accepted as a leper. Speaking about Eric Christian's murder, Reynolds remarked, what really bothers me is that whoever did it, they're still out on the streets laughing about it.
他对自己被判有罪并被判终身监禁感到震惊，在狱中他继续宣称自己无罪。监狱生活对雷诺兹来说尤其困难，因为他被判犯有针对儿童的罪行，他忍受了狱友的暴力和强奸。在狱中，他告诉记者，他觉得当局针对他是因为他是同性恋。雷诺兹的律师呼应了这种情绪，补充说圣约瑟夫普遍存在的恐同心理意味着他的当事人融入并被接受的机会就像麻风病人一样渺茫。谈到埃里克·克里斯蒂安的谋杀案，雷诺兹评论道：“真正困扰我的是，无论谁做了这件事，他们仍然在街上嘲笑这件事。”
By the time Charles Ray Hatcher confessed to Eric's murder, Melvin Reynolds had served four years in prison. There was even a moment in time where Hatcher and Reynolds were incarcerated together, although they never crossed paths. The reason why Hatcher had willingly come clean after all this time was characteristically selfish. He knew if he was found guilty of murdering 11-year-old Michelle Steele, he would most likely face life in prison. By admitting to killing Eric Christian, his outcome elevated to the death penalty. Charles Ray Hatcher wanted to die. In the weeks that followed Hatcher's confession, Special Agent Joseph Holtzlag worked on building a rapport with the self-confessed killer and visited
当查尔斯·雷·哈彻承认谋杀埃里克时，梅尔文·雷诺兹已经在监狱里服刑四年了。甚至有一段时间哈彻和雷诺兹被关在一起，尽管他们从未有过交集。哈彻之所以在这么久之后愿意坦白，其动机是典型的自私。他知道如果他被判谋杀11岁的米歇尔·斯蒂尔罪名成立，他很可能会面临终身监禁。通过承认杀害埃里克·克里斯蒂安，他的结果升级为死刑。查尔斯·雷·哈彻想死。在哈彻供认后的几周里，特别探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格致力于与这位自称杀手的凶手建立融洽关系，并经常在监狱里探望
him often in jail. He had already established the identities of four of Hatcher's alleged victims, Eric Christian, Michelle Steele, as well as his longtime friend James Churchill, and fellow prison inmate Jerry Tharrington. Yet, by Hatcher's own account, there were another 12 victims he had yet to name. Holtzlag walked a fine line when seeking more information, as pushing too hard would no doubt cause Hatcher to go into one of his prolonged states of silence. Realizing he held the position of power, Hatcher toyed with the agent accordingly. After promising to write a diary detailing his crimes, Hatcher informed a frustrated Holtzlag that he had flushed the papers down the toilet. He instead handed over a handwritten poem
他。他已经确定了哈彻四名所谓受害者的身份：埃里克·克里斯蒂安、米歇尔·斯蒂尔，以及他的老朋友詹姆斯·丘吉尔和狱友杰里·萨林顿。然而，根据哈彻自己的说法，还有12名受害者他尚未说出名字。霍尔茨拉格在寻求更多信息时如履薄冰，因为逼得太紧无疑会导致哈彻陷入长时间的沉默状态。意识到自己掌握着权力，哈彻相应地戏弄着这位探员。在承诺写一本详细记录他罪行的日记后，哈彻告诉沮丧的霍尔茨拉格，他已经把纸冲进了马桶。他反而递上了一首手写的诗，
that read in part, whose to know as days go by, only me and I won't tell, because I'm on my way to hell. The day is drawing very near, the one you all want to hear. That time has come, I have to go, and now no one will ever know. Agent Holtzlag took the poem to mean Hatcher was refusing to make any further admissions. Yet, there was a confession hidden in Hatcher's past that Holtzlag was able to uncover. During one of his many stays in mental health facilities, Hatcher had told assessing psychiatrists about an image that often plagued his mind. As detailed in the book Innocent Blood, the vision began with a boy riding a bicycle. Hatcher would then watch himself driving a car with the same boy riding happily in the passenger seat.
部分内容写道：“随着日子一天天过去，谁会知道呢？只有我，我不会说，因为我正在去地狱的路上。日子越来越近了，你们都想听的那一天。时间到了，我必须走，现在没有人会知道了。”探员霍尔茨拉格认为这首诗意味着哈彻拒绝再做任何供述。然而，哈彻的过去隐藏着一个霍尔茨拉格能够揭开的供词。在多次入住精神卫生机构期间，哈彻曾告诉评估他的精神科医生，有一个画面经常困扰着他的大脑。正如书《无辜之血》中所详述的那样，这个幻象始于一个男孩骑自行车。然后哈彻会看着自己开着车，同一个男孩快乐地坐在副驾驶座上。
Next, Hatcher's thoughts cut to a creek bed where he stood over the boy with his hands wrapped around his neck. Unbeknownst to the medical professionals who heard Hatcher relay this vision, it hadn't manifested out of nowhere. Looking through records, Agent Holtzlag came across the August 1969 unsolved murder of 12-year-old William Freeman in the Californian city of Antioch. William had spent the afternoon playing tennis before riding home on his bike. One of his friends saw a green car pull up to William who spoke with the lone male driver. Hours later, when William was reported missing, his bicycle and tennis racket were found on the sidewalk where he had stopped to speak to the man in the green car. Two days later,
接下来，哈彻的思绪切到了一个小溪床，他站在男孩上方，双手紧紧掐住他的脖子。听到哈彻讲述这个幻象的医疗专业人员并不知道，它并非凭空产生。通过查阅记录，探员霍尔茨拉格发现了1969年8月发生在加利福尼亚州安条克市的12岁男孩威廉·弗里曼未破获的谋杀案。威廉那天下午打完网球后骑自行车回家。他的一个朋友看到一辆绿色汽车停在威廉身边，威廉与唯一的男性司机交谈。几小时后，当威廉被报告失踪时，他的自行车和网球拍被发现停在人行道上，那是他停下来与绿色汽车里的男人交谈的地方。两天后，
two children exploring Los Trampas Creek came across a young man on his hands and knees by the creek's edge. His head was extended downwards as if drinking the water trickling by. It was the body of William Freeman deliberately posed in a manner as if to disturb whoever came across him. He had been choked to death. William's case went cold until 14 years later when Agent Holtzlag connected the crime to Charles Ray Hatcher. Hatcher had been in Antioch at the time, driving around in a stolen car. William Freeman marked his fifth known murder victim. In August 1983, the Office of the St Joseph News Press received an envelope addressed to the newspaper's editor. Inside was an anonymous handwritten letter that read,
两个在洛斯坦帕斯溪探险的孩子在溪边发现了一个年轻人跪在地上。他的头向下伸着，好像在喝流过的水。那是威廉·弗里曼的尸体，被故意摆成一种令人不安的姿势。他被勒死了。威廉的案件一直悬而未决，直到14年后，探员霍尔茨拉格将这起罪行与查尔斯·雷·哈彻联系起来。哈彻当时就在安条克，开着一辆偷来的车。威廉·弗里曼是他第五个已知的谋杀受害者。1983年8月，《圣约瑟夫新闻报》编辑部收到一个寄给编辑的信封。里面是一封匿名的手写信，写道：
Sometimes the system makes a very bad mistake and I'm not just blowing steam as you will find out soon enough. It's a real stinker and should really shake up some of those of the criminal justice system in your fair city. It's been in the making for some time but just beginning to get ready to blow. Keep your ears open. Agent Joseph Holtzlag knew the letter was from Charles Ray Hatcher, who was hinting at the injustice of Melvin Reynolds' wrongful conviction for the murder of Eric Christian. Holtzlag was in the process of having Reynolds' case reviewed by the prosecuting attorney Mike Insko, who'd been responsible for securing the guilty verdict. Insko was initially less than enthused about reexamining the case with the mindset that he
“有时系统会犯一个非常严重的错误，我不是在发牢骚，你很快就会发现。这是一个真正的烂摊子，应该会震动你们这座美丽城市刑事司法系统中的一些人。它酝酿已久，但才刚刚准备爆发。竖起耳朵听着。”探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格知道这封信来自查尔斯·雷·哈彻，他在暗示梅尔文·雷诺兹因谋杀埃里克·克里斯蒂安而被错误定罪的不公正。霍尔茨拉格正在让检察官迈克·因斯科审查雷诺兹的案件，因斯科曾负责确保定罪。因斯科最初对重新审视案件不太热心，认为他
had been wrong about it. But upon viewing Holtzlag's evidence proving Melvin Reynolds' innocence and Charles Ray Hatcher's guilt, Insko understood. Hatcher was their guy. Still, there were many more setbacks to come from others not wanting to admit error. Holtzlag later said, I was naive to think that everybody would work just as hard to get an innocent man out as they would to put a guilty one in. But they couldn't give a shit. On Thursday, October 13, 1983, Charles Ray Hatcher stood before a judge and pleaded guilty to the murder of Eric Christian. He was sentenced to life imprisonment with a non-parole period of 50 years. Despite Hatcher's guilty plea and the supporting evidence gathered by Agent Joseph Holtzlag,
在案件中犯了错。但当看到霍尔茨拉格证明梅尔文·雷诺兹无罪和查尔斯·雷·哈彻有罪的证据后，因斯科明白了。哈彻才是真凶。尽管如此，由于其他人不想承认错误，未来还会有许多挫折。霍尔茨拉格后来表示：“我太天真了，以为每个人都会像努力把有罪的人送进监狱一样，努力把无辜的人救出来。但他们根本不在乎。”1983年10月13日星期四，查尔斯·雷·哈彻站在法官面前，承认谋杀了埃里克·克里斯蒂安。他被判处终身监禁，不得假释期为50年。尽管哈彻认罪并有探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格收集的支持证据，
St. Joseph police chief Robert Hayes stood by his initial investigation and was opposed to overturning Melvin Reynolds' conviction. He said he was dumbfounded by the court's decision to accept Charles Ray Hatcher's confession. Melvin Reynolds was sitting in the Missouri State Penitentiary's visiting room when his mother Wanda entered. The pair sat together on a couch and as Melvin began to speak, Wanda interrupted him, saying she had something important to say. Another man had confessed to murdering Eric Christian. A flood of emotions washed over Melvin as the realization dawned that his prisoner deal would
圣约瑟夫警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯坚持他最初的调查，并反对推翻梅尔文·雷诺兹的定罪。他说他对法院接受查尔斯·雷·哈彻供词的决定感到目瞪口呆。梅尔文·雷诺兹正坐在密苏里州立监狱的探视室里，他的母亲万达走了进来。两人坐在沙发上，当梅尔文开始说话时，万达打断了他，说她有重要的事情要说。另一个人已经承认谋杀了埃里克·克里斯蒂安。当意识到他的囚徒生涯即将结束时，一股情绪涌上梅尔文的心头。
soon be over. Melvin Reynolds later said that he never felt any ill will towards those who found him guilty, accepting he was largely at fault for giving a false confession. He didn't plan on seeking monetary compensation and just wanted to get on with his life, telling a reporter, My freedom is more important than any lawsuit could ever be. The day after Charles Ray Hatcher appeared in court to plead guilty to Eric Christian's murder, Melvin was officially a free man. In the aftermath of Melvin's vindication, St. Joseph police chief Robert Hayes was criticized for his handling of the case. He still refused to reconsider Melvin Reynolds' guilt, instead expressing his belief that perhaps
梅尔文·雷诺兹后来表示，他从未对那些判他有罪的人怀有任何恶意，承认他因做出虚假供词而负有很大责任。他不打算寻求金钱赔偿，只想继续他的生活，告诉记者：“我的自由比任何诉讼都重要。”在查尔斯·雷·哈彻出庭承认谋杀埃里克·克里斯蒂安的第二天，梅尔文正式成为自由人。在梅尔文平反后，圣约瑟夫警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯因处理此案的方式受到批评。他仍然拒绝重新考虑梅尔文·雷诺兹的罪行，反而表达了他的信念，认为也许
Melvin and Hatcher were co-conspirators. He accused FBI Special Agent Joseph Hultzlag of feeding information to Hatcher and was staunch in his opinion that evidence implicated Melvin over Hatcher. So overt and vocal of his controversial stance, police chief Hayes was eventually issued a court order forbidding him from publicly discussing the case. While other investigators were more willing to accept a wrongdoing, one told the press, If there's anybody to blame, Melvin's to blame. It's a shame his character was so weak that he confessed. Authorities in various counties endeavored to identify further victims of Charles Ray Hatcher. He offered no help either because he wanted to remain elusive or because his chronic alcohol
梅尔文和哈彻是同谋。他指责联邦调查局特别探员约瑟夫·霍尔茨拉格向哈彻提供信息，并坚定地认为证据指向梅尔文而非哈彻。由于他的立场如此公开和直言不讳，警察局长海耶斯最终收到了法院命令，禁止他公开讨论此案。虽然其他调查人员更愿意接受错误，但其中一人告诉媒体：“如果有人要责怪，那就是梅尔文的错。真丢人，他的性格太软弱了，以至于他认罪了。”各县当局努力查明查尔斯·雷·哈彻的其他受害者。他没有提供任何帮助，要么是因为他想保持隐秘，要么是因为他长期的酒精
abuse meant he couldn't remember enough details of his crimes. There were several crimes that fit his MO but it was confirmed that Hatcher was either in jail or hospital at the time they were committed. There wasn't enough evidence to bring Hatcher to justice for the murders of William Freeman, James Churchill or Jerry Tharrington but in September 1984 he faced trial for the murder of 11-year-old Michelle Steele and was found guilty. The jury would decide if he received a life sentence with a non-parole period of 50 years or the death penalty. Hatcher made his preference clear by announcing in court, If you think I did this you have one job, you have to make sure it doesn't happen again. I have a record of escapes, I may try it.
滥用意味着他记不起足够多的犯罪细节。有几起犯罪符合他的作案手法，但证实哈彻在这些罪行发生时要么在监狱，要么在医院。没有足够的证据将哈彻绳之以法，以惩罚他谋杀威廉·弗里曼、詹姆斯·丘吉尔或杰里·萨林顿，但在1984年9月，他因谋杀11岁的米歇尔·斯蒂尔受审并被判有罪。陪审团将决定他是否会被判处终身监禁且50年内不得假释，还是被判死刑。哈彻通过在法庭上宣布明确了他的偏好：“如果你认为是我做的，你有一项工作，你必须确保它不会再发生。我有越狱记录，我可能会尝试。”
You must prevent it from happening again. The bewildered judge told the jury to disregard his comments and an hour later the jury announced their agreed upon sentence, life in prison. The St Joseph community were outraged but those who knew of Hatcher's desire to die took solace in knowing he didn't get what he wanted. Four days later at 4am a prison guard making the rounds at the Missouri State Penitentiary shone his flashlight into Charles Ray Hatcher's cell and discovered that the 55-year-old had taken his own life. He hadn't left a note. Prosecutor Mike Inscow told the press that he didn't believe Hatcher had been driven by remorse but quote,
“你必须防止它再次发生。”困惑的法官告诉陪审团无视他的评论，一小时后，陪审团宣布了他们商定的判决：终身监禁。圣约瑟夫社区感到愤怒，但那些知道哈彻想死的人在得知他没有得到他想要的结果时感到欣慰。四天后的凌晨4点，一名在密苏里州立监狱巡逻的狱警将手电筒照进查尔斯·雷·哈彻的牢房，发现这位55岁的老人已经自杀身亡。他没有留下遗书。检察官迈克·因斯科告诉媒体，他不相信哈彻是出于悔恨，而是引用他的话，
total frustration at being caught and knowing that the world saw him for what he was. Due to Hatcher's prolific use of aliases and interstate offending, none of the psychiatrists who assessed him throughout his life were fully aware of the extent of his offending when making their evaluations. Even though it was their reports that led to him being released time and time again, their ignorance shielded them from any legal ramifications. As written in the St Louis Post-Dispatch newspaper, Hatcher cunningly turned the mental health system into his own private sanctuary to avoid criminal prosecution, then used it as a path of least resistance back to freedom.
“完全是因为被抓获而感到沮丧，并且知道世界看清了他的真面目。”由于哈彻大量使用化名和跨州犯罪，在他一生中评估他的精神科医生在进行评估时，并没有完全意识到他犯罪的程度。尽管正是他们的报告导致他一次又一次地获释，但他们的无知使他们免受任何法律后果。正如《圣路易斯邮政快报》所写，哈彻狡猾地将精神卫生系统变成了他逃避刑事起诉的私人避难所，然后将其用作回归自由的阻力最小的路径。
The extent to which Charles Ray Hatcher assaulted and murdered his victims will never fully be known. In total, Charles Ray Hatcher was convicted for three attempted abductions, six abductions with sexual assaults, two murders, and had likely committed three others. However, he claimed many more. Among investigating officers, Hatcher earned himself the moniker, the one-man crime wave. Melvin Reynolds found life after his exoneration challenging, with many people still convinced he was involved in Eric Christian's murder. He died in May 2012 at the age of 58. St. Joseph police chief Robert Hayes intended to write a book about the case titled You Be the
查尔斯·雷·哈彻袭击和谋杀受害者的程度将永远无法完全知晓。总共，查尔斯·雷·哈彻因三次绑架未遂、六次绑架并性侵犯、两起谋杀案被定罪，并可能犯下了另外三起谋杀案。然而，他声称犯下的罪行远不止这些。在调查人员中，哈彻赢得了“一人犯罪浪潮”的绰号。梅尔文·雷诺兹在平反后的生活充满挑战，许多人仍然确信他参与了埃里克·克里斯蒂安的谋杀案。他于2012年5月去世，享年58岁。圣约瑟夫警察局长罗伯特·海耶斯打算写一本关于此案的书，书名为《你来做
Judge, which would outline why Melvin Reynolds was Eric Christian's killer, but the book never eventuated. Hayes eventually wound up in prison himself after shooting dead his neighbor following a physical altercation. He served eight years in prison for involuntary manslaughter and died four years after his release at age 81. One of the reasons the former police chief remained steadfast that Melvin Reynolds was Eric Christian's killer, despite evidence and a confession to the contrary, was because of a two sentence letter written by Charles Ray Hatcher. Hayes received the letter when the process to have Melvin exonerated was underway. It read,
法官》，书中将概述为什么梅尔文·雷诺兹是埃里克·克里斯蒂安的凶手，但这本书从未出版。海耶斯最终在一次身体冲突后枪杀了他的邻居，自己也进了监狱。他因过失杀人罪在监狱服刑八年，并在获释四年后去世，享年81岁。这位前警察局长之所以坚信梅尔文·雷诺兹是埃里克·克里斯蒂安的凶手，尽管有证据和相反的供词，原因之一是查尔斯·雷·哈彻写的一封两句话的信。海耶斯在为梅尔文平反的过程中收到了这封信。信上写着：
Chief Hayes, you're right about the Christian case. I didn't do that one. Good luck, Charlie Hatcher. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“海耶斯局长，关于克里斯蒂安案你是对的。那件不是我做的。祝好运，查理·哈彻。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。